how about now okay
well anyways why don't we want to go
ahead and get started actually have to
admit I was on my way down to 124 and I
thought boy if I didn't remember it was
there I wonder if anyone's gonna
remember and if anyone will show up and
then I walk over here and see all of you
anyway some I guess we moved we moved it
into this room because of when they have
more capacity and I was actually gonna
start off by saying you know I've been
talking about how how analytics and
related topics are important but sort of
seeing the turnout here makes validates
that point anyway some I want to thank
the folks from Kaiser for coming over
today and sharing with us of what
they're doing some of you know for me
that you know this this is a key future
direction for our field and it'll be
interesting to hear what's what's
happening at Kaiser and what
opportunities there are for students and
others to participate in that so an XE
being like good analytics folks I don't
know if there's a name like Anna
laticious like in fermentations but
anyways being good informatics folks I
got a schedule that had it like down to
three minutes for this two minutes for
this and and of course we messed it up
because we're running a few minutes late
but anyways I'm sure I'm sure it'll be a
very interesting presentation I'm just
going to introduce Brian and then
hopefully he'll introduce the rest of
his team
Brian Sakura is the director of the data
and information management enhancement
or dime kind of sounds a lot like the
mice and he's been at Kaiser since 2000
he's originally from Pittsburgh and he's
been in Oregon again since 2005 his
bachelor's degree was obtained from the
University of Pittsburgh in finance and
he has a master's in Healthcare
Administration in Portland State and
from Portland State and he will tell us
about the work that's going on so I
don't know whether you want to hold that
or try it okay do you guys hear me okay
okay cool so we're happy to be here with
you this morning to say thank you for
having us I know this is our first big
event to know Hsu with this lunchtime
talk and hopefully it's on our last
we're hoping to establish more frequent
interactions up here and with some of
our local universities today we really
want to talk about um career
opportunities and healthcare analytics
and really what I mean by that is them
will talk about give an overview of some
of the skills Lisi is required to be
successful in these roles as it relates
to what we do everyday kinds of
permanente through that talking with
some examples of projects that our
analysts participate in every day and
more so we are gonna try to reserve
about half the time safe for some Q&A
with you guys like an interactive panel
discussion so that's that's kind of what
we have in store half of our group
today's from the health plan side of
Kaiser Permanente and half is from the
Medical Group side and we'll I guess we
actually know what we'll do introduction
of few minutes start off a quick video
just to give overview of our
organization and some grounding on some
of our core principles values of them is
tight as a whole but we also embrace
within the analytics community
a wise man once said we are oh I'll let
you read it yourself done okay you
noticed he said we not you or I but we
Aristotle was a pretty smart guy he knew
that the power of we could do amazing
things I mean look at what we did we
taught the world to thrive that's the
power of we we've been part of an
amazing transformation we've carried on
the incredible legacy of dr. Sidney
Garfield and Henry J Kaiser two other
pretty smart guys they believe that
health care was about keeping people
healthy not just treating the sick they
believe that health belonged to everyone
that information had the power to
transform medicine some called it
experimental some called it socialism
today the world calls it visionary
that's because we believe health isn't
an industry it's a cause that's the
power of we we changed the way people
look at health by focusing on the
balance of mind body and spirit we
inspired people to live a healthier life
we not only talk the talk we walked it
ran it biked it and Yoga debt we lived
it we created more than an ad campaign
we created a movement and we enlisted
some wonderful friends along the way by
dr. Preston Maring
who declared the kitchen every bit as
important as the clinic
welcome to my kitchen who brought
farmers markets into low-income
neighborhoods schools and right into our
lobbies and dr. Bob Salas who told us
that health begins with a single step
followed by another and another and next
thing you know you're walking your way
to lower blood pressure reducing the
risk of diabetes and combating
depression that's the power of we
together we made a difference we helped
people to stop smoking start moving and
eat better we reduced broken bones and
seniors by 41% we lowered hypertension
by 80% and we reduce deaths from heart
disease by more than 30 percent compared
to the rest of the nation we saved lives
now we are getting noticed a five-star
ranking for Medicare quality and service
highest in member satisfaction from JD
Power and Associates number one in
customer loyalty in the Net Promoter
benchmark study number one
eleven diversity in top 50 companies and
fast company named us one of the world's
most innovative companies in healthcare
for our leading-edge work with
electronic medical records how about
that our Center for total health in the
nation's capital shines is a testament
to our founders vision and we're lending
our voice to pressing health issues the
way of the nation is out of control but
we can fix it that's the power of we in
1960 dr. Garfield envisioned computers
as a way to transform care delivery
today we have the largest electronic
medical record system in the world my
health manager connects our members with
their caregivers millions of times a day
we are pioneers in telemedicine and da
Vinci robotic surgery giving even remote
areas access to expert care we launched
the KP mobile app giving people one more
way to take control of their health and
their family's health we're leading the
way in social media we're sharing our
stories and our members are sharing
theirs together we are changing the
future of healthcare and together we
will continue to teach the world to
thrive
working up may we all live will be well
and I'm just gonna go ahead and say it
thrive
so I like the we as a keyword when it
comes to analytics and especially
analytics inside Kaiser Permanente's as
I mentioned half of us are from the
health plan half of us are from the
Medical Group but despite those
divisions we are primary care we are
specialty care we are hospitals we are
contract hospitals with OHSU we are
insurance and call centers and denture
labs and mail-order pharmacies in order
to bring all that data together turn
that data into useful information to
help our our regional leaders help our
clinicians with the answer with the
answers they need to help solve the
problems they have to solve to improve
healthcare in our region we have to work
together and we we have to collaborate
and we have to we have to bridge that
gap between all the data that's being
created by our systems and our
clinicians and our leaders and so with
me today is some of the some of the key
folks from Kaiser Northwest that
participate in our analytics program at
Yvonne Zhao who is a director from the
Medical Group we have Allison Schmitt it
is a manager within the health plan
Keith Kurland who's a manager within the
health plan Desiree was one of our
recruiters from the Medical Group Debbie
a recruiter from our health plan shin
Fang is hiding behind the wall is a lead
analyst with our Medical Group and
Delilah is a lead analyst with within
the health plan organization you'll have
a chance to interact and have questions
answers from all of these folks today
and more importantly afterwards we're
all gonna be available for networking
and one-on-one
as well I encourage you to take
advantage of the panel discussions today
if you have ideas that spark and
definitely ask them we want to hear your
questions and we have some just help get
started we'll have some canned ones
again get things moving my advice is you
go through this day and listen to the
listen into conversations when it comes
to skills that are needed to connect
people to data and information the true
core of analytics and there's really
three table stakes in my opinion one is
programming skills you have to be able
to extract it integrate and analyze data
and that means starting with a blank
screen and being able to use sequel or
SAS or a program like that to extract
data from a data warehouse or a system
and integrate it together to produce a
reporter analysis you must have critical
thinking skills in a methodical approach
to solving complex problems and finally
that bridging skill key communication
skill 'some clearly deliver nuanced
information and insight to diverse
audiences because not everyone is
trained and understanding even standard
deviations a mean mode let alone more
complex reports or information so you
have to be able to deliver that
information in a way that will be
received by your audience so I say as
you listen and you think about what
you're hearing today is like think of
those think of them from my skill set
respect that means in those three slices
and with with that general introduction
maybe Ivana is going to talk about them
some of the solving of them so how we
apply analytics to solve problems in
healthcare and I think then after that
we'll get more into these skills up on
the individual level good afternoon
everybody
can everybody hear me okay it's really
good to see that many people in the
audience
i'm just-just manly about 15 years ago
when I got my PhD in biostatistics at
the USC there were not much
opportunities either you go to a
pharmaceutical industry to be a
biostatistician or you stay in academic
to do cancer or epidemic research but
right now is a really exciting moment an
exciting time so I'm going to talk a
little bit about
so so again analyticals is executing
your terminology anybody in the field
like a fifteen ten years ago oh you
heard the data management analyses or
statistical analyses but other
definitions analyticals keeps changing
and expanding so here's a put in your
terminology so it's about systematic
reviews of the data and also discover
business insights it produces a lot of
new applied analytical discipline so
we're come for statistics we talk about
contextual we talk about a quantitative
predictive as well as some of the new
emerging methods like artificial
intelligence machine learning so there
are so many new things are coming and if
you some of you like to be creative and
innovative the field is really a wide
open it is also trying to with all those
insights really come to inference the
operations of vinius it's Drive
fact-based decision from planning
management measurement and the learning
traditionally when you do let respective
analyses or maybe even clinical trial I
guess some oh you know perspective work
but nowadays really descriptive
predictive really want to understand the
work will happen as well as the
perspective basically it's not just
super get to what what happened and how
it happened at that one can point that
gave you some new options and
probability and so you can make a
decision based on what information
provide to other managers so healthcare
is really going tremendous change and
those are fundamental transformation
they've changed
so it used to be okay how many pieces
have you done how mayor many tax rates
have been done and those are the claim
system that we get reimbursed but now we
are regular moving to a value-based
system and a business so it's really to
drive bad outcomes
a more productive and efficiency of the
care delivery and the in addition as you
are probably all aware we have a
wonderful company called epic that we
are all using there are products and
which creates in the house killer
industry and those second paradox it's a
plus so we get lots of information that
we can use because the traditional and
collecting data is the most expensive
venture now we have so much data but
it's also in a way the people say we
have too much data and we don't have
much insight because data sometimes
could be at third a and you have to
clean up you have to understand the
workflow and make it a meaningful and a
useful for healthcare organizations yeah
increasingly looking at analytical's as
a kind of market a differentiator to use
it to consume a lot and apply new
insights for information so to add
clinical and operational improvements to
meet business challenges as well as some
of the transition information to produce
a report to help us to make decisions so
iBM has been survey to 100 healthcare
executives and asked them whether they
use analyticals
in those three categories so you can see
that the leading companies
use the analytical's as to inform
decision-making and strategy and the
sales marketing is found much more and
compared to other average perform of
organization so analytical's is really
important for us to meet the challenges
and to move forward and without reading
the market
so in general analyticals can be used
during those three categories to solve
the business problems so one has
improved clinical fishing effectiveness
and the member satisfaction how we treat
the patients how they interact with
patients how we understand our patients
and also the number two is improve
operational efficiency can we reduce the
waste can we make things happen quickly
and then the last one the financial and
administrative performance so there's a
lot of areas and it in a way any areas
can be used for analytical so I'm going
to just give three examples and I'll
show you how we in the Kaiser Permanente
use analytical to help solve the
nation's problems so the first one we
caught up to its operational support
tool to improve operation efficiency and
speed it is a tour that I'm providing
near New York on data the information is
coming from epic back and the database
and data are being refreshed every 15
minutes and we use this to help people
my clinician leaders and managers to
really operate clinics and help them to
understand what's going on out there
and so they can really take action in a
moment before the opportunity goes away
and as you also see I think analytical
to emphasize the visualization data
visualization so many of the display was
today our colors data help our users to
see sings important areas much quicker
and clearly so in terms of analytical
skills I think Ryan has taught for three
categories certainly you know critical
thinking and as well and communication
and cannabis are very important but if
anyone comes to me and the first thing I
want to learn about that person to
understand that person whether he has
general interested in quantitative or
what has he invested in the analytical
because as you can see whatever the come
to work is very complex and a Weber
comes to us they you you don't have all
the experience because it's really brand
new area so it's really come to
understand and really train somebody
takes a lot of energy effort but they're
also requires the determination from
them person so those kind of things I
think a way you know look at her first
because it takes effort to a partnership
to make that happen but in terms of
analytical skills epic data if you have
knowledge about ethical data you have
knowledge about ethic it's tremendous
plus because I know people in our chest
here you probably get chance to you know
expose to some of those kind of
information with lot of data mining and
the really cleaning up the data so you
have
the sense which data might be children
hypothesis how do we validate this
correctly that is around data and takes
lots of applet and analytical critical
thinking as Brian pointed out metrics
tab development within consider a high
and analytical work it's usually our
operation leaders come to us saying I
wanted this metric I want a average wait
time at a at our office so but they
don't know what back and the data is and
so you have to really understand the
workflow and bring this information
together and then display in a way that
are useful for them this is a specific
work because the Lewises a New York I'm
a real-time data engine and it's very
challenging so if you just say Papa data
quality real-time data and this will
valid when you learn levels of hmm a has
a performance school so Amy and raises
the quality data bar into very high
level and and mixing so complicated and
machine full moon who sits there is
really the mastermind behind of it
because the data analytical engine is a
very very challenging and then have you
can see we need to do the VI to display
the data as well as the cells next one
is a really weak or the patient support
tool and this is a web-based tour and
designed to enable clinicians to manager
they are panel patients that planning
care needs and preventive needs and as
you can see this is a one novice panel
and it can be sorted in any way
according any of those columns the color
scheme us Unitel doctor exactly what
other protocols behind of it so they
don't even know need to click on it
so it's efficient for physicians to use
and so it's
that are either for average so have
their ms to competence those other
patients with diabetes conditions that
they need to take care of certain are
preventive care or treatment protocols
or when the DUP when a patient that
comes in and then you click on the
patient with order et al are care gaps
plus so doctor can just quickly reveal
all those things and it's not as primary
care doctor could be especially care
doctor and the way action last I was
dental care because patient that comes
to see then Dennis for every year of
topic just every year and those are the
really great opportunities to reveal
care gaps and make sure all the things
being met
yeah so how to manage it the end of life
and we all know that health care cost
the last the younger people's life is
about summary of all periods life yes
together so complex Pia is actually a
really good area to relate in pool
operating efficiencies and also
effectiveness and our patients are
telling us many of them they don't want
died in the hospital they want to die at
home with their loved ones and so but
this is a is a way that a window each
patient is kind of a bit different it
depends on what age group if you are
ages this is an algorithm developer for
aged over 65 so if you are patients or
members under their healthy and robust
days don't really need to see the
adopters often but if someone have
carnival conditions then we're going to
want to make sure that they follow all
the treatment applies and then some of
the complex care patients and they
really require case management them and
the social support and so we use big
data we use part of epic data powder
with some of the data marts we have
created a form CMS as well as other
purpose and they put together and they
use a computer algorithm that are
classified patients into those four
categories and because of different
categories that care needs are different
and their social needs are different and
how we provided clear and so it's the
algorithm has been validated by um
clinicians and it's about like um it's
pretty high come coordinates and we are
actually about to publish a paper about
this work so so with the data you can do
lots of things and those are the three
examples to join how to use data
analyticals to
some business problems this is a
recently this year that by Brian
circular that loss Westar just went
through analytic data analytical
strategy reset and I trying to see what
we want to do for the next five years
and he has a very clear vision in the
mid update the vision we want to do it
we really want to be lead at the market
in using personalized integrated
information to bring to the house value
to our members and excellent analytical
insights for care delivery in religious
health plan and a Medical Group cannot
come together and are trying to achieve
what we can do to help her
leader the health care industry and the
other top the awkward really identified
five the key areas that we think we need
to put a more focus and be more
structured the more systematically and
in those areas and unfortunately being
asked to leave the middle one that
innovation and advanced analytical
office so so we are all really excited
about all those five areas and I think
that will help us to be doing more
advanced analytical's that will really
help us make that here operation more
efficient and a productive there are
also some of the fundamental areas that
are really important you know have to be
data governance which is extremely
important to make sure that definition
is the same across single source of
tools across all the reports how do we
managing our resources to be productive
as well as the hard work I will keep our
talents
and the core Menace basically related a
lot of work that we have to do to keep
our life live keep our killer operations
going and a coordination we kind of work
together about to make more cinematic
collective use another way as we want to
work together to make it implement over
the past several years Allison I've
probably screamed thousands of resumes
and conducted hundreds of interviews for
sure so for the next few minutes alice
is going to talk from from that
experience in her role as managing a
large piece of our development team and
alice is going to talk about the
analytic analyst rule roles we have that
Kaiser and some of the court required
skills of for being successful inside
those girls okay so I'll try to get us a
little bit ahead here we also some of
these members are three if we don't get
through all over this time we do a
summary section as well so this I'm not
I'm also too short if I would see them
talking so this picture really just as a
representation kind of how the roles all
work together there's really blend of
all of our roles into each other so it's
not like they throw things over the wall
when we work on a project it's really
many of our projects require all these
roles to be successful I think the other
thing I always say is that this isn't
representing all the IT roles we have
the Kaiser as well we have over a
hundred and ten thousand employees
nationwide we have an IT Center that's
here that it's in a lot of really
technical roles many of these roles are
technical but they also require a
business focus I'll talk a little bit
about some of the skill gaps that we see
for making the ideal candidate so
starting over here the business systems
analyst this is kind of a traditional
role that's existed in every industry
every application the user interaction
with the source system changing the
workflow information on demand somebody
in the room his wife is an application
coordinator at Kaiser for epic this is
where they actually manage the
application modules within epic - to
take that workflow and information in so
this is all about the information into
the system if you have any exposure to
data information in get you to better
quality on the other side right so part
of what we have to do is make sure we
understand where we have to have solid
workflows where the informations because
they said and what we need real-time
information in the system to help the
operations make the center than we go
through the day
this portion here the data warehouse
data store if you're from those epic
clarity is a data store for us we have
over 150 source systems at Kaiser at any
one point only have different systems
for our claim sales recruiting the old
data we get that data out of data
warehouses sometimes a real-time in many
cases it's day leg month leg penny
often those data stores are updated most
of that works done by IT data movement
those kind of functions are meeting the
IP functions for us then we get into the
data analyst role and the reporting on
this role the team that I managed
primarily makes up of these roles and
they're also these roles on the from the
other side data analysts in focus on
data marts synthesizing information from
disparate sources so an example I would
give is being a question for my business
that's how many referrals are over 45
days old that result in in emergency
department visit at our Hospital mental
hospitals right that seems like a very
fair question because we want to reduce
for a backlog get people into the
specialist quicker well that requires
going to claims so you see our outside
hospitals our own electronic network for
emergency departments a referral
management system and maybe even bility
to understand those kind of questions so
we have to take these four different
sources bring that to answer those many
questions
that's the kind of work we do in the
data analyst space reporting analyst
base tends to be more information
presentation out that's where it's
scorecards reports we use a variety of
tools when our main bi tool that we use
is Cognos and talk a little more about
the skills that we get there so if we're
presenting information that tends to be
more on the report cites inputting
information tends to be on the
businesses and the outside the data
analysts sort of pull information from
many different perspectives to put them
together overarching on the top of the
information in what's wrong I kind of
call this the umbrella role this is
probably our most advanced rule for
statistics
forecast we model even have several
people in this room that we've brought
with us that play this role they also
are the key to help synthesize what
question are we actually trying to ask
what information do we need to answer
that question
so definitely need the technical skills
that this is probably the core role that
really helps us to get to that root
business problem that we're trying to
solve how we install that with
information so that's kind of the
general overview can you go to the next
slide thank you
this is the state information that you
have on your grid so this 42 the same
rules across the top that we just
reviewed I won't be this in detail but
anyone hit a couple of highlights you
talked a little bit about the main
function already the core products for
the business systems analyst that
process system configuration for the
data analysts and smarts tables via a
metadata framework report in less is
more of a historical trends information
dissemination scorecards information
analyst lots of different touch points
their analysis requirements queries
forecasting data minds and quite a wide
variety of space of the information
Alice get in it's also our largest all
set at Kaiser there's a little bit about
the service they provide and then the
core skills so to be an effective
business is some nailless you definitely
have process engineers go so you'd be
able to take what it's print workflow
it's the attendant workflow or the
changes you'd be able understand how
that system needs to change to reflect
those what's that human interaction with
that system and what you know what
information is really needed within that
to make an effective workflow for you
also be that typically you need some
kind of knowledge in the business area
so we talked a lot about health care but
we have 25 businesses of one live lab
pharmacy imaging we don't always get a
full mix so if we can get a partial mix
of somebody to you on point will train
them the ability to do that
learn be creative fun new subjects
really get in and understand context is
really a core skill when we get to the
data endless space meeting experts equal
logical physical modeling or main base
design cognos staff symptomatic of BI
tools many of the people from this world
come from IT backgrounds the course
skillset that I tend to not fly into my
mercury it's something that can put the
context of the business problem and
really make that translation between the
business and the IT and actually do the
work as well so those that's gonna be
the core the core skill set that lacks
it you got anything as someone that's
got all the technical and they can't
describe anything about their project or
have someone that can describe the
project as I am no idea and just can't
offer some developers something so those
are usually the two ins the spectrum on
the candidates that when they come in
with equal pay this is a candidate
that's usually there on one end of the
spectrum another so you can blend those
two things you look at the market the
data analyst report analyst we're really
looking for you know immediate level
sequel some kind of BI reporting tool
there's variety we don't really
necessarily pigeonhole anybody but our
tools change the Train on this we expect
people to be able to adapt the emergence
of the data visualizations who are
coming up in this space some of the
connection taken synthesize information
visually for people was really growing
in this area information analyst again
medium sequel SAS to States industrially
and behave after Islands deep some cases
phd's if we're lucky so these are these
are the kind of skill sets that were
looking for there so they couldn't live
with them examples of work
go the next slide so thanks Iman
bottling into quite a bit of detail so
I'm not gonna repeat every she probably
went a lot more detailed examples these
are some of the example products people
in this room recently worked on Carmen's
IT team design solution not vertical
reports for Department workflows
so actually taking that clinical
Department figure out what didn't even
do to improve the meeting the workflow
changes we see partnered with leadership
team of transitions of care program to
develop reports they identified the
highest risk patients currently or
recently discharged from the hospital is
the reports that used by care teams
interactive patients during and after
their discharge to try to make sure we
have a great care plan for them I try to
keep them from coming back into the
hospital this is part of July that's
working out so we its panel you cry
speak to this anymore
if we go the next page thank you
so the next one debated integration
foundational data marts integrated
claims hospital inpatient data I spoke a
little bit about that question earlier
on there's some kind of work that our
data analyst lead on my team has done
built the Cognos business intelligent
that provide operations with the ability
to track ill time throughout the region
so again every company has attendance
issues right for us it's really
challenging you get a staff a hospital
certain level we've got to make sure we
have the right people in the clinics we
don't want sick people treating their
patients that could make them more sick
so maybe you shouldn't be having regular
time monitoring or we have real-time
the year for staffing issues those are
kind of business questions we also get
into as part of organization appointment
utilization for specialty care
departments we implement improvements to
appointing the scheduling we're always
trying to get appointment site moves
down lower so we get our patients
through the doors more often and the
last one was the some of the more work
for they adopt you so I think that was
all of the yep so that's any what are
your questions we'll have some time at
the end as we all have a panel and we
have a pretty good mix of both skill
sets here so you have specific questions
but this kind of gives you this summary
again something with some variation by
rule by job position that comes open
because projects are very specific but
it's not always like we've got to have
the checklist of the client rate or the
touch the person applying we won't make
sure we have adaptability as well
because the tools to use my users are
completely different the project we work
on six months ago is completely
different
we have allergy needs we're constantly
changing so that ability to adapt was
probably number one thing the problem
for the technology thank you thank you
it's not cute allisonville Island
shipping are gonna come up for more of a
panel discussion so we can see some of
the questions you may have and try to
stump the analysts a little bit and
we'll use the balance of time for a Q&A
and interactive discussion so if you
have a question here just stand up and
ask and we will do our best to answer
while you mentioned about how the tools
change and other jobs and academic
programs have is that they
have the resources to report the tools
that organizations use what do you
recommend - you know students who want
to you know get skills maybe not exactly
what those tools but but similar kinds
of skills that they would be easily able
to adapt the kinds of tools you use so I
think if you look sequel shows up but
everything once almost every tool we
have is really a single writer it does
that but if you have a core and
understanding how you put programming
language together and then you can under
you have the skill to adapt and learn a
tool rapidly of how you're gonna make
that logic more efficient with the tool
that's what I would say the master
because that's probably the the core
skill set that threads through all of
them and is a core to understand any
toilet and there's guessing this open
source programs out there too that are
good for learning are open bi and using
like census data American Community
Survey like you can do a lot of like you
can build skills on your own of working
with complex messier datasets as opposed
to just might need nicely textbook
package data set so using some those
free open source programs because the
thought process is once you master the
thought process learning agent
application is much easier that's among
the information I'm sorry
saxs program you so today we will
program most programmers
if you really are seems to be pretty
widespread if someone was very
technically trained or yeah I mean we I
don't see especially at Kaiser and I
think in health care I don't see SAS
come ever really going away completely
because it is so deeply ingrained within
our organizations and but if you if
you're confident are and you you're
confident mastering the techniques and
the program that in taking the leap from
your learning your first program your
second it's much smaller going from your
first to your second your second to
third so I think it's late good good
solid experience with a tool is
important and I think ours would be fine
you mean nobody in a first year in the
requested breakfast today such as we
have so you may have a
specific consulting project you're
working on with the client
my whole bunch different sources some of
there's more assurance plan kind of
member sends it in summer wool some on
this panel of local listings yeah it's
kind of like the question we just do
that parallel to that axis will switch
over to Sax's we've done it I guess my
question is worried about your
application infrastructure have you guys
ever thought about
software design challenges because I
know I think the government also has a
kind of projects they have these open
source challenges to design a particular
tool
I think that's interesting yeah yeah
just for analytical for us so outputs or
analysis will day where we will spar a
lot the time people they know that they
need to deck in some way so we
prioritize
which has pretty much every part of the
healthcare system and just being able to
put governance around how we take intake
so I mean it's a great idea
but when you said that there was a vast
variety of types of problems of utilize
come in and it's just kind of sitting
through that frontal line resources this
is a big challenge in itself because
there is a huge demand out there which i
think is great on the back with the
healthcare system specially on the EMR
side we've gone through that choices of
where they need three months is
electronic that's great our Kaiser we
can normally find somewhere you know
ones we've linked with health record
number we can pull information together
we've done some great water it's a it's
greater than that point the downside is
there's a huge amount that people want a
sip
so there are many of them really work
with the conditions to configure some of
the functionalities but not having the
finishing and that one away
aya P and also we expect them to you
know use their skills more populate so
they could be more as a nice Mia we call
the subject matter expert gonna help
with if we develop some applications
reports whatever tools more clinic we
could make it and so they can help with
that gap because it's critical to make
sure the clinical information is aware
they are useful ever be by the actors so
that's one areas but they could be also
the accounting at Medical Group and help
to adopt some of the ridiculous
and trying to be earlier against another
Chairman is trampy experiment and trying
to see how to use some of the tools for
the efficient array so it's I think it's
like a bridge between the clinical and
and there are juices on the operational
side of the world if you have within the
ostlers to really try to fight see the
processes and patient flow and that's
integral working with the doctors and
the nurses of Astral right now Freiburg
deep tunnel of our medical knowledge
within that together with understanding
date with type of data skills improve
that isn't it I happen to be a clinical
research type his operational questions
that are embedded within clinical
operations always really mention that a
lot of the responses that are heard
tenable to me can have a strong
component of master data management I
was just wondering about you know what
kind of framework do you employ that are
at Kaiser to ensure data quality data
validity and what opportunities exist
for our students to come into those
those fields we employ chaos we we
actually we have strategies I think more
of a local level than we do at a
national level so part of what our
organization recognizes is that we don't
have a master data management strategy
for member so member can show up in 30
plus systems 4000 reports is that manage
data metadata that pure the capital m
and master data management health but at
the local level the strategy we employ
is trying to make sure we have a really
good business definition that's approved
and reviewed and we understand the
context of that definition so member
membership there are two different
things
subscriber member are different things
in some cases you do need different
definitions because they are something
different and there's a business context
so the idea doc understanding and
documented the business rule
understanding documenting the logic that
goes into that and being adaptable who
in the business context or needs change
we try to really build
that stuff into the data marts that's
really our strategy at the local level
at the national level there's many
efforts to try to put more of an
enterprise-wide master data management
and data visualization processes into
trying to make improve that but I think
overall behind the industry in those
practices enterprise level it's not
always right use the EMR and our next
week that's how I do the data validation
yeah we both have completeness and
accuracy against the source whatever
that source is so all of those
traditional data analytic techniques
will employ but I think for master data
management big ass were behind the
Affordable Care Act it seems like the
business model for everyone might change
dramatically she looked at member
recruitment member retention and what
members are going to want so are you
looking forward to doing things that are
more page
like patients desire and going and
serving patients more of what they want
from their organization because they're
gonna have a lot more choice we've
already kind of did some of these we've
done some text mining were looking at
complaint states aspirations around
using a wall kind of board or multi
points of the patient's things like when
men is calling with issues or problems
or requests about catching the
information being able to process that
some of that because I think that is
it's an area where there is a great need
and yeah we don't have that much so I
think there's a business aspiration for
it we have done some kind of research
projects we've done some other work
looking at modeling patient potential
member attention trying to identify the
pooling across a very broad
characteristics remember to be able to
start to look at one of the things that
drive changes within that
the way that they see a lot of interest
I think right now Washington efforts
will be going into just being able to
actually operate with the changes coming
in the marketplace just a very operation
well that's a lot of challenges on the
data side sometimes they come between
the analytic side and the IT side is
just like this Medicaid population
increases requirements puts a lot focus
on how about seven bit we have done some
work in exasperation I think great
opportunity earlier slightly same sales
and marketing as a little more
traditional thanks - event apply then we
have done some small project challenges
and it
and how can we extend that for us so
it's what to come by the way looking at
that so it's a policy at that early
stage six to fifteen you okay so I'm
going to take just a little bit of time
too whereas other insurance companies
are good hands
you guys actually advertisement yet so
what are you advocating for behavioral
change that prevent chronic disease and
as a public health physician I've always
really appreciate your partnership in
that then I do have a question and one
and you said that you had a big burden
in terms of data requests so how do you
prioritize those do you have a user
group or do you have an executive team
you do that we constantly try to get
better fired up I think our our tent
alone receives probably anywhere between
five and eight requests a week and and
these are the typically these aren't the
ones that you can answer in like four
hours or less these are the ones that
might take four to six months to answer
them so the backlog continues to grow
and we use a process of constant
reprioritization conce review every two
weeks we review our intake so we we
planned quarterly so that we we try to
set our development efforts by a quarter
so we keep our analyst focused and then
we basically leverage our region's
hoppers to teach an operating plan to be
our compass of what
most important and the senior leadership
vice president level always has override
so it's a it's it's messy but it kind of
works them one of our challenges was one
Yvonne and I trying to work on with the
new strategy refresh is getting more
consistent in how we manage and
prioritize across the health plan and
the Medical Group side so that word we
have a more consistent and transparent
process between the two because having
Kaiser Permanente is actually multiple
organizations on in one so we have two
we have the way some internal barriers
with honey mixture centralized groups
sort of able then to send and manage
that where this is our existing ways to
come in will they be able to manage that
in a decentralized way well in a
centralized way but out of that we're
trying to look for the how that connects
with the for the strategy for saying we
want to start feeding strategy to add
this into the back of the building the
big mark so that we can switch that work
over and make sure that have fun an
analyst with cycling lots of components
rather than create do the job and you
just get the stuff to support so we
it wasn't actually configure our
resources and tablets to get the best
especially my question very simply is
just question that was so important and
it's actually the element of teacher
retention and responsibility patient
come on that what you're collecting dues
data because a patient satisfaction so
when so when there is we actually the
part of my team does that we have
benchmark surveys that we participate in
through kind of the standard vendors
that do this kind of work we have
regulatory requirements of places that
we do this so when there's an encounter
whether it's a home health worker in
your home or physician that's seeing you
in a medical office building when
there's an encounter we collect that
data and do you identify it send it to
the vendor and they administer surveys
that actually benchmark of satisfaction
against other people in our industry and
against ourselves and we can actually
compare our our satisfaction is going up
but this clinic versus this one what's
happening what are they doing different
than this one or we also can know see
what we're performing in select the
government regulations every part of
that in some of the cases the heat is
scores which other quality we look at
like the tests the you know closing of
the care gaps some of the patient panels
the patient support tool that we talked
about we actually use that tool so that
we close care gaps that's one of the
reasons why we have such high scores and
closing those care gaps and have ever
achieved our ena scores and so if having
the tools available to deliver the care
while the person is in the office I'm
about to turn 40 I'm gonna have a whole
bunch of care gaps because I turned 40
so when I go for my visit with my doctor
and an annual basis when I walk in
they'll say hey I'll set haven't seen
couple years you're not 40 you need to
have these tests right there they can a
mr. gold the orders I can do it before I
leave the clinic they can do it all
right there so I get it closed so all of
that integrated healthcare that we are
built on helps us achieve those gaps
that we do so there's kind of a mixture
of satisfaction as well as like actually
a delivery the care to tip where we get
those high scores there's just a pilot
taking place but I think the whole in
the industry is a whole there's a lot of
60 minutes we are saying book club on
these kind of topics there's a lot of
this emerging but there's privacy issues
and you know there's we sell the years
of the physician interaction with a
patient and clinic which was a movement
away from the physician interaction with
the patient in their home right now it's
coming back to that through technology
so we're gonna change a lot in five
years but I think that Kaiser's got
pilot programs but it certainly hasn't
become part of the the every day but you
know Skype visits and some of these
things even the regulations haven't
caught up to give us credit for those so
the government will catch up at some
point but we certainly have two pilot
programs one of the I was gonna close
but instead that special election bank
did shine the light on the student think
and I'm talking also I can see if you
want any closing comments that we will
wrap the only thing I'll say is I came
to Kaiser about four years ago
in Kinesiology meieran applied
statistics not a real heavy programmer
but I picked it up fast steep learning
curves there's a lot to be thought that
Kaiser but the longer on there before I
learned and I absolutely love it it's a
challenge every day but being able to
have access to so much information and
feel like you're impacting the patient's
remember it's a very powerful so it's a
really really fun position to have and I
closed for six years
be fine to join the tables three years
ago
and when I was in Boise I was a second
and say no without any people but having
to type Kaiser and apparently even may
help out your little tasks every people
are using like a signal sequence insight
expands and then it's just like a with
the the master mechanism hugely faced
and within each other it has a lot to
learn but with all the teams working
together and there's and video and any
thinking problem-solving skills and then
and obviously make sure you can think
outside of the box and when you think
about a lot of information and a lot of
skills of reworking behind I have
learned a lot in the master three years
Anderson I mean I think kind of a pro
wider a huge opportunity for you just a
couple and like to build up use your own
skills and
probably the thing about how school a
year and the reach of the probe I mean
underneath been a year and depending to
the front and the I and dashboard
explain later
anything I think there's also all the
curricular skills
thank you for spending time with us upon
say we're happy to be here take some
food because we don't have room to get
it home and we're gonna be here for a
while so many watts questions like feel
free to come up and ask us